now my next guest has made a successful
career in rugby with both
england and heart england and harlequins
but joe marla is also loved for his
quirky haircuts and comedic tv
interviews
like this one we've got another week to
to get back on the horse you know and
take that horse to the water
and you can ask that horse you can say
hey horsey do you want do you want to
have a drink
or do you want to swim yeah and it's up
to that horse to then realize
what he wants to do in his life and that
horse at the moment
wants to go out on saturday he wants to
clippity clop all the way to
the stoop he wants to say hello to those
fans and he goes
and he goes i'm sorry about the
last week but i'm going to give a better
performance
here at home against bath he's a
slightly irish horse
but despite being known as one of the
game's jokers joe marla has now
discussed his struggles with his mental
health
in his new autobiography loose head and
he joins
me now joe thank you very much indeed
for being with us and as we saw in that
clip and we're all smiling
and you have a reputation as as being
the joker
of the pack you're a big guy with the
tattoos
with the mohawk which i believe is now
gone and
how much of that was the real joe marla
or how much was that
your professional character as it were
to mask
some of the the other troubles you were
feeling
um well just just to comment on that
video that you've just played there i
was actually trying my hardest to be
quite poetic and serious but it seems to
have been um
misinterpreted as as somewhat i think it
might be the accent
oh okay i'll work on my accent your
horse your eyes
yeah uh no uh yeah there is a big part
of that that um
i i play up to it a lot and play up to
that sort of
character side of it because it enabled
me to sort of cope with
um being in the spotlight with rugby a
bit more
um and not really seeing it as real life
and not understanding it like that and
that was the best way i cope with it
but yeah i enjoy having a laugh and i
enjoy
what i do and that clip went viral
you gave many other people a lot of a
big laugh and a lot of joy as well and
people looking at you on the pitch
thinking this guy has it all a
successful career with harlequin
successful
england career and yet underneath that
there were times when
you were driving to training in tears
you wanted
that career to come to an end one way or
another
just tell us about that
yeah um like you've described i've
i've um always been a bit of a joker
always
tried enjoying myself as much as i can
with rugby um
but in recent years i've i've struggled
quite a lot with with who i
really am and who i think i am or who i
thought i was
um and it wasn't until a couple of
incidents that had happened in my life
um started to hit home that i then
started exploring
um how i could sort myself out how i
could
get through the darker times how i could
cope with depression
and first of all accept it and then once
i've accepted it
understand it and work out ways in order
to
to move forward a happier guy because
to be quite honest with you the biggest
issue i had was that i didn't have
a lot wrong in my life
i've got a lovely family a loving wife
my friends and my job i'm very lucky for
the job that i do
but um which was even more confusing for
me that i couldn't pinpoint why i was
i was sort of almost feeling ungrateful
about having all these opportunities
in front of me and and not really
uh enjoying them as much as i could
you write in the book about a
disciplinary hearing
and you went into it and you did open up
in that hearing and but there was almost
a sense of disappointment when you got
a short ban and a big fine and actually
at that point
you wanted a long ban you wanted an out
um sorry max give me two minutes
to me no no give me two minutes
family life brilliant family life uh
yeah no there there was a bit of
disappointment in me
because it was another
sort of route of right that means i'll
be away from the game longer which means
you know because i kept blaming it on
the game on i kept blaming it on
something else and never really owning
it
that it was it was something that was
wrong with me
that i needed to address um
but i mean i'm in a much better spot now
and i'm more
more capable and more told up in in
terms of dealing with those
those feelings and those emotions and
and that's how i am now
and you're speaking out about it
importantly in a game like rugby very
macho alpha male dominated
uh sport how difficult is it to have
those kind
of conversations
yeah it is is tough we we're definitely
getting
much better as a sport talking about
mental health more opening up more being
more accepting
that we do even as our males
even aggressive rugby players that we
are
we can we can we can still have issues
we can still have problems and we can
still talk
um to each other and and be those guys
we can also still have a laugh and we
still
can take the mick out of each other a
side of talking and helping each other
with with different problems that we can
have um
so if i if me speaking out a little bit
more can
can help others in my sport and others
outside of my sport
um feel more comfortable about opening
up
them than great you talk about a couple
of incidents
i wonder what it was that that took you
to the lowest point the point at which
you felt
that was the time to to ask for help
yeah there's a talk in detail in my book
about
um the the particular incident that took
place at home that that was enough
that was enough enough was enough for me
um my lowest point
and uh it was around march time
um in 2019 that
i then ended up speaking to the club
doctor and
getting help and then he put me in touch
with um
a professional and an independent
professional
that that could then start exploring
what was going on and
um yeah um looks it
well it's great to see you great to hear
uh from you joe marla thank you very
much
indeed if you want to find out a bit
more lots more
about uh what joe has been through and
how he's coming through
in his book